Here's a very simple threaded program that uses POSIX threads,
or p-threads as the library is also known. We'll discuss POSIX
threads for the remainder of the lesson, but most of
the concepts will apply to all thread libraries. The entry point
for our process is main, as always. And main will
spawn two new threads, t1 and t2 which will enter at
the procedures f1 and f2 respectively. That's why we passed the
function pointer as we create these threads. These functions become like
the main of our other threads. And as we see,
these threads are going to print out a message over and
over that says that they are the better thread. Notice that
main we have this join method. We'll discuss this a little
more later, but basically this mean that the thread is
going to wait for thread one to finish before it goes
any further. And then join with thread two means that it
will wait for thread two to finish before going any further.